[Music]
Jenna has control yeah all right sorry
but I'm not really sorry if you don't
know what theme song we just I'm not
gonna stop you no no a theme song that
was it was the Game of Thrones theme
song we switched our seats back because
you guys were very upset about this
switching yeah you didn't like that so
we I gave her control of the summer that
might be anyway guys right now this
episode is brought to you by the skin
guys have you no time to read all the
news you want the skin makes it easy for
you it condenses all the top news
stories puts it in a nice little
newsletter and submits it to your email
every single morning all right so go to
this skim that's th es ki mm ComStat
annejulien
and your email right now and click
Subscribe that's today
you don't have to do anything else it's
free they send you a nice packaged
informational little email every morning
all right so you can dominate your
conversations at work yeah so brought to
you by nature box guys you want to eat
better but when it comes to snacks it's
pretty sketchy and it's hard to eat good
snacks okay naturebox takes the
guesswork out of that because nature box
makes great tasting simple ingredients
snacks free from artificial colors
flavors or sweeteners right now go to
nature box calm
you got a nature box not calm flashy no
Julian and you get three free snacks
with your first order guys hard to beat
really great snacks vegan friendly
gluten free friendly as you know we like
them too also a certain sponsor this
week is the tracker pick so guys I know
you lose your wallet and your phone only
dammit
the tracker has a tiny coin buys device
that helps you keep track of your
belongings and dogs their new tracker
pixel is the smallest tracking device on
the market okay it's this it's the
lightest Bluetooth device out there it's
tiny
you put on your things and it connects
to the app right now go to the th e TR
ACK are the tracker comm promo codes
angeline get 20% off any order Thank You
sponsors give us some good breathing Wow
we literally like just got home from we
went to Pennsylvania for a wedding one
of my best friends in college I lived
with her for a bunch of years yeah she
got married and it was so fun but it
took forever for us to get there because
we had to fly to Philadelphia just like
a five hour flight away there six on the
way back and then drive two hours to
where the wedding was and so we did that
in Reverse today and just got in and
took like an hour and watched the finale
Game of Thrones so that we could use the
internet tonight dinner like I'm dying I
feel weird I feel gross I think we got
sick on those trips we did we woke up
with a little cold this morning which
was oh no fun trick though yeah I think
I felt like multiple kinds of shitty
this morning yeah feel good yeah so
we're in Austin we're recording this you
know Sunday night so you guys just to
give you a reference of where we're at
with Austin pretty exhausted I'm
exhausted figured we would just hop on
here and give you guys kind of a chill
podcast tonight I like to chill we like
food might literally get here in the
podcast guys I feel throw-up sick but
it's still Sunday cheat day Sunday and I
ordered me some tacos for me because I
feel like I'm actually gonna throw up do
you really still feel help you Oh ginger
candy oh no no it's okay you have to do
that okay okay I don't know if anyone
saw my snapchat though my my actual
[ __ ] literal best friend in the world
Jackie she was cracking me up at the
wedding I was [ __ ] crying laughing
because the last time that I saw her we
would get to see each other that often
because she lives in Boston yeah the
last time that I saw her was her wedding
yeah so we didn't get to really kick it
and have a lot of fun because she's
getting married obviously but at this
wedding it was like no time had gone by
Jackie going Jackie that's pickup like
you miss any time yes this [ __ ] so
we're like hanging out drinking whatever
I don't know if you saw us after or not
but this [ __ ]
all of a sudden pulls out a banana clip
hey I don't even know where you could
buy those anymore
Amazon weird where honestly she's
probably had at her entire life she
pulls out a [ __ ] banana clip and
Clips her hair up and I was like what
the [ __ ] is that and she was like it's a
banana clip showing from the front look
how cute it is from the front look at
these flowing flowing locks I was so
[ __ ] like there's no words friends
don't let friends wear banana clips on
ironically at someone else's wedding the
audio here so Jeff sorry okay you do
that but then the other thing so our
friend Jill had like a photo booth at
our wedding and Jackie like we're up
there obviously were several drinks in
and there's a couple probably related to
Jill in some way but like they have an
infant baby like this thing looks like
it was born no less than a week ago in
fit baby so we're all up there you know
we got the the photobooth stuff on
Jack's got giant sunglasses on I put a
tiny red hat on we took like a gigantic
group picture with like 15 people and so
we're all sort of like making our way
out of there because we see this couple
the baby has like those construction
headphones on and suddenly it looks like
it was just born just born making their
way because the small little area we're
like making our way out of there rolling
Oh
cuz they're carrying a it was just
[ __ ] born and we also had just
finished yes that you're leaving yet so
Jackie with her giant glasses doesn't
see the baby at all doesn't see this
photo booth process at all like we're
all like on like moving this way Jax
gets back in there
pushes the thing to start the photo
booth that she's sitting like this and
I'm like Jackie you literally just
stepped in front of an infant baby to
take a photobooth picture of yourself at
the wedding you know giant pears unless
did this girl cut off a baby and a
banana clip with sunglasses she did it
with Costello and it was a great picture
just draw a baby and parents in the
background really like I really hope
that she was also the one that was like
after he took the pictures she didn't
like one of them she was like oh nothing
happens it doesn't go anywhere I'm like
that's you I really hope that Jill has a
picture of Jackie cutting off an infant
baby in the photo but yeah we got to
find it and tweet it oh my god you it
textual even though she's not having the
texture right now it was like shocked so
then we went to like a small bar after
like the after parties we're in the
middle of nowhere
we're in Titanic Titanic ton kinetic
anak I don't know Pennsylvania but we're
in a small bar afterwards and I look
over we could talk about this in a
second but Julian was watching the Conor
McGregor flayed me with a fight and I
was sort of looking in on my phone now
well until were a lot of people
obviously people are interested in it
know I'd be watching on my phone and I
look over and I was watching that for a
hot second until I was incredibly
distracted by my best friend in the
world Jackie who was Stanton after she
cuts off a baby after she puts her hair
up in a [ __ ] banana cliff after she's
getting kind of drunk and just [ __ ]
living life this [ __ ] is overstating it
like a dishwasher like rack full of
silverware and I was like Jackie what
are you doing she's like she's taking
them individually out while mumbling
something about you got to do the side
work and the third of the country knows
what side work is and she's wrapping up
the silverware in napkins and like
putting them together
as a server you're not at work right now
she genuinely was like no I just gotta
get done this is gone again I was there
for that decision by the way she was
sitting next to me and we were talking
about the fight and all of a sudden she
gets fixated on the fact that there are
a basket full of dressed you know
silverware packets the way they're
wrapped up and already and then there's
baskets of non dressed silverware a
finding it yeah what am i finding I
don't know you tell me listen to Jackie
talk
describe what she's doing this is after
I was already mad at her for she tried
to scalp me on the dance floor at one
point but she wanted to put the padana
clip in my hair it felt like that true
scalping me it looks pretty good she
grabbed my head she was grape snap
banana clip against my scalp but I was
like I did not fly in a plane for five
hours to drive for two and a half hours
to get here and get scalped by a banana
clip Jackie girl oh no baby what is you
doing what do you have against banana
just like please already hit me I'm just
wondering it was just like such a weird
thing in like the like you had them in
the 90s just excited straight a ponytail
kind of no it's like this weird flat
long thing going on it's like not right
it wasn't right when it was a thing and
it's not right now guys I'd like to know
your opinions on banana clips cuz I'm a
little on the fence here I'm on the
banana clip fence
[Applause]
[Applause]
like not responding to the next one the
next one makes absolutely no sense
amazed that's Jackie in a nutshell no
one stopped her it's not like someone
was like folding sofa regulate excuse me
ma'am
can use jhana I actually encouraged her
doing that by the way Jimmy because she
was gonna do it and then she got
discouraged because she couldn't find
the little paper wraps and I was like oh
they're right there so she's like okay
and then started going at it do decide
work I'm just gonna do the side I would
have to disagree with you though if I
was at work and there was a whole mess
of silverware that has yet to be
organized and someone was doing it
drunkenly I'd be like knock yourself out
what is the worst that can happen do you
do it poorly and someone else gets
blamed for it who's gonna be checking
with the quality and summer.i tomorrow
right that's if you trust that she's
actually wrapping the silverware she
could have been doing anything over
there that's true
hi Kermit did you miss your mommy never
cried for like an hour just cause he
missed us miss your mommy huh my glue
baby needs to be glued to his mommy at
all times
[Music]
[Applause]
Floyd and Connor
you're my thoughts yes well I I think it
went pretty similar to how I thought it
was gonna go and I mentioned like a lot
of people want to know my predictions
and I basically had said something along
the lines of like you know Connor is an
incredible boxer in MMA but Floyd is the
best boxer in the world in boxing hmm
and you know I had a I wasn't gonna be
the person to say like Connor couldn't
win but I also was being kind of
realistic like you know Floyd's gonna
win this fight mm-hmm it's not a fight
it's a boxing match Floyd's gonna win
looking back on how well Connor did and
how the fight panned out I'm wildly
impressed with Connor I think the fact
that he landed I think 111 punches on
floor I'm Floyd Mayweather the guy who
is the best at avoiding damage out of
anyone landed I think 11 more punches
than Manny Pacquiao landed on floor if
you think
that's pretty crazy and I think it just
kind of solidified Connor as like a real
you know tried and true boxing threat if
anything I'm kind of glad it's over
because I'm ready for him to like fight
in a Romanian I mean this whole build-up
was fun I'm not gonna lie and like
here's the thing is entertaining they
announced the whole thing I was I was
ready to just like you know kind of quit
be like I don't care about any of this
but then they started to hype it up they
went on the main back tour and it was
really cool it was really entertaining
they sold a hell of a fight
they're both to like incredible you know
personalities and they did an amazing
job but watching it and watching it pan
out watching it and I was like okay this
is great this was history I'm glad it's
over
that's not doing let's just do some
Moreno and I know I'm not a huge boxing
fan but you know I didn't hey I didn't
hate the fight um it was impressive to
watch Connor the first three rounds and
it was also very impressive to watch
Floyd just do what he does yeah I didn't
really watch anything so I was laughing
at Jackie but like at first when I heard
about it I was like no I'm not gonna
watch it that's a [ __ ] circus it's a
freak show is making a mockery of
everything and then you know I same
thing I started warmed up to it but then
I'm actual fight night when we're at
Jill's wedding I was like our doing man
I just don't [ __ ] care yeah you know
like I thought I was gonna care and I
really just do not care
well cuz it's a it's a boxing match yeah
we were talking about how much of my
sorry I apologize for my sniffling guys
it's okay we're talking about how much
money both of them obviously made and
you if you didn't get that many people
to care about you and watch you live
like you earn that money but I'm like yo
Chuy for like seventy five million
dollars or whatever I want you to knock
me the [ __ ] out yoke I will gladly let
you just knock me unconscious for
seventy-five million dollars are you
kidding me we've been doing this YouTube
thing all wrong what we gotta do is we
gotta do pay-per-view bruh
Khaled you just knocked me the [ __ ] out
for 75 million dollars here here it's a
great ideal offices of YouTube we say
we're like we'd like to meet with
YouTube red team Lisa tell us is a ok
how much money do you have
Oh like now what is in your YouTube red
Vick cuz I'll take all of me we want all
of it I'm gonna knock my girlfriend out
while I live on YouTube okay actually
we're the inflatable Rock'em Sock'em
boppers yeah knock around with that
mm-hmm
we'd like all of the money please but
I'd also laid like half of it in advance
have to go on a press tour for it yeah
after I lose I'd like to take on
jacksFilms 30 pounds of muscle cut on
that Birdman you're abusing this up see
a bird raising dogs 75 million that bird
can knock me out
for 75 million dollar jacksFilms you can
knock me out with whatever weapon of
choice the dark side enough of that
that sounded like a helluva I was trying
to sell the fight okay well he hasn't
even accepted he sign the contract a
savvy buyer really Dolly's there is no
accepting it's just a yes Jack if you
would like to come on our podcast and
deal with this whole thing cuz what is
this you traitor
I'm kidding Jack's always welcome we
Cecchini Oh Oh No Oh live vomit yeah
yeah [ __ ] how dude
and I was this is a weird night it's a
weird night I'm gonna be our beer oh
please don't eat that honey I'm gonna
BRB we'll cut it real quick we'll be
back Pete she's not feeling well guys
and I know you probably all know what
it's like to not feel well but that
would never happen if you order nature
back some snacks you don't just throw do
something with that we stopped the
podcast Oh guys right now go to nature
box are cops watching Julia you get
three free snacks first or not nature
box has got you covered with over a
hundred snacks that taste amazing in our
kitchen you can feel great about what
you're eating
are made with simple ingredients free
from artificial flavors colors or
sweeteners you won't throw them up I
don't know him
they also have vegan gluten-free paleo
low-fat options every snack is full of
flavor to keep your taste buds happy my
favorite artist strawberry fruits are
the size which they send me a box with
like 30 of them yeah ate them all yeah
you do oh please they lived in the
cabinet free-for-all
okay being serious enough because I know
I checked them you ate most anyway
you're sure you guys are gonna be sure
to find you a new snack obsession with
nature box right now I'm gonna name sure
voxcom slash Jenna Julianne get three
knots free with your first order please
stop that coconut cashews strawberry
lemonade fruit stars they have a lot of
really good options here are the worst
also right now if you guys don't have
time to read the news get this skin
newsletter they send you a nice packaged
newsletter every morning with all the
top news story so you can dominate your
conversations at work knowing everything
you need to know without having to do
all the research and look in yourself
Google and because of this game guys
you're gonna learn about everything you
need to know including don't goof around
for this part seriously including things
that are really pressing like the
hurricane
hurricane Harvey in Houston which by the
way we're gonna include a link in the
description if you guys want to donate
her or do any sort of donation or text
message they're accepting any sort of
thing for for the Red Cross to help out
but it's really horrible what's going on
there it's not to bring it down but all
the top news stories on the skin right
now go to this skim that's two M's
that's th es ki mm comp slash annejulien
and to your email you subscribe and you
get the first email from the skin
tomorrow morning it starts immediately
okay it's free guy's hand right now if
you go to schedule you get entered for a
chance to win a $250 gift card and in
our last sponsor of the day is gonna
prevent you from losing your wallet keys
your phone your dog your drone your
backpack your suitcase the tracker ever
changed everything eight years ago when
they released our first tracking device
and then they've done it again with the
all new tracker ah pixel it's the
lightest Bluetooth device out there it's
tiny it's like it's a tiny coin size
device guys and it doesn't only work if
things are lost in your house okay can
track things from miles because it is
part of the largest crowd locate network
in the world it connects via bluetooth
to your app you can locate your items
and it'll play a sound or you can find
it on the GPS map go to the tracker
that's th e TR ACK are.com promo code
generally get 20% off any order thank
you to all of our sponsors my tassel OCA
okay I'll get it it says three minutes
all right it's here then you go outside
they're out there we joked about that
last episode
so aside from being tired and sick we
did have a fun time this weekend not
only at the wedding but try to through
Pennsylvania and spending some time out
there was really nice
plus we got to be together and we were
talking about that which others are
calling well we were just travel with
this
let's find out marks I'm definitely fun
to have on our trip and it was it
reminded me that even like the short
weird wedding trips or whatever it's
it's just nice to take a trip with you
mm-hmm
enjoy a little weekend whatever and this
weekend was nice it was really any part
it was like it was in a barn the what is
it him it was like literal Pinterest in
there it was unbelievably outside it
literally just looks like a nice nice
barn on karma farm and then you go in
and it's like holy [ __ ] they like decked
it oh wise literal Pinterest it was it
was like the Pinterest farm and then I
went down to the kitchen yeah it was a
fun time she leaves the room and all the
dogs followed her if this was twitch
right now I would probably tell you guys
a prank that we would play on her when
she gets back but this isn't live so we
can't do that but you know what is live
is the h3h3 podcast and we're gonna be
joining them for an episode this Friday
September 1st we are gonna be going on
the h3h3 you know in fact I think it's
actually called the h3 podcast now with
Ethan and nila we're gonna be hanging
out with them doing the thing doing the
podcast thing so we'll give you guys
more details on that we'll probably
tweet it out from the pot our podcast
account and likely our individual
channels as well incredibly excited for
that because we've known them for some
time now more recently in person well
we've been internet friends for a long
time and I have too recently hanging out
and been gaming with Ethan a little bit
they're super super rad people and tell
them about this Friday we're going on
the podcast pastry yeah well my Taco
Bell yeah I'm like excited and also
nervous on their projects I'm not
nervous I'm excited it's gonna be pretty
cool yeah you know I'm only nervous in
the sense that
like I literally don't go on anyone
else's anything so I'm just so used to
like having the control you know our own
podcast our own channels do any of that
get the kit well I on the technical side
I'm excited to see their setup like
their five see what happens and
everything and you know whatever but I'm
also I'm like the only nerves is like
I'm going out someone else's podcast you
know that's like you're on you're on the
away turf you're on your home turf but
I'm excited because there's no way game
coming up we got a wager on the way
basketball game Friday wait can we were
matching outfits on the HOV pod yes
sure go she will get jump seats yeah
probably
okay I mean it just seems like the right
thing to do yeah yeah no I just got it
you guys take at least like one good
bite no but I'm still in that point
where I can't decide if I don't feel
good or I'm definitely don't take a bite
then definitely don't take a bite acid I
diet talk because it's for cheat why do
you shake your head sounds so weird
BAM
[Music]
on the front of twitch though I haven't
been playing pub G because they've been
out of town and busy the last week I
think I think it's time to get nice and
addicted I agree
hey guess when I watched on the plane
what a show called big little lies tell
us about it so there's this woman
sitting next to me I'm playing on the
way there because me and Julia both had
middle seats because we booked it flex
it too late then didn't really check in
and all it was I forgot that was
supposed to do that and so we both had
middle seats but they were at least in
front of each other like me and then
Julian was behind me and the woman
sitting next to me was like this older
an Indian woman dressed impeccably
[ __ ] beautiful like a pink top with
matching pink pants and like she had
that beautiful clip in her hair there
was like glittery spark I was dying so
she was sitting next to me she was in
the window seat I was in the middle seat
and so I turned on Project Runway and I
slowly realized that she was just
sitting there with nothing like not
reading anything that she's just
watching just watch she was just
watching over my shoulder the whole time
and at one point she was like are you a
designer and I was like oh no I usually
like this show she's like it's super
beautiful and I'm like I know and then
she was like and then this that there
but like I don't mind do you mean like I
didn't mind at all cuz it's you don't
need to hear the sound to watch like the
cool outfits it's totally harmless but
so you guys I only had three of us
guilty of looking between seats and
looking at PE TV's play like but they
don't know I'm doing it that's right
they were what is that I only had like
three episodes Project Runway and then I
started watching a show called big
little lies which is on HBO it's like
Reese with it what are you doing don't
do that and I'm like an episode and a
half in or something yeah I was enjoying
it like I like it it's a good show and I
was getting cuz really one season yes
cuz it just started okay so I was like
getting kind of invested I'm like this
is pretty good there was like you know
an hour and a half maybe left in the
flight and then it gets like and I'm
still aware that this woman is watching
everything
there it's basically here iPad when I
say older I mean like maybe my mom's
agent maybe in her 60s or so yeah and um
but yet scene where this woman's husband
is sort of like [ __ ] roughing her up
like beating her up and then it turns
into this bizarre like now they're sort
of having sex but like angry like
violent sex was it like rapey at all or
yeah I think this is your food guys
they're different food and I was like oh
my god so I started [ __ ] like
freaking out a little bit what are you
doing oh yeah it's your food so I
started freaking out a little bit like
oh my god what do I do like should I
shut this off should I keep it on like I
don't know ever been on a plane and
you're watching something that's like
kinda graphic or like kind of sexual and
you're also aware that other people are
like looking at your screen but it's
like it's a make-or-break moment so I
basically took my iPad I pretended to
laugh at it I put it facedown put it in
my backpack
and then got my phone out play candy
crush for like an hour and a half the
rest of the flight because I was too
embarrassed sit there and watch this
like aggressive sexy with this woman
watching over my shoulder but who knows
maybe she was like disappointed more to
see where that scene was going I don't
know maybe she started to feel it oh my
god so you remember how like when we
travel Rome would always on our iPad
watch Geordie Shore yeah
which has just like straight ass and
titties and [ __ ] and like all nasty
[ __ ] on there and she'll be like on a
plane and you'll look over at her and
she'll just be like like like I hire
iPad I would make it a point to like
look at her at the most uncomfortable
moments just to make her because like
like when it's like super inappropriate
and you look at her she's extra
sensitive to eyeballs she's
self-conscious yeah but I told you that
one time I watched Million Dollar Baby
over someone's shoulder completely on
silent
I didn't see any i watch the whole film
with no audio
I mean I got an idea yeah it's boiler ok
she's a boxer ok and and then an injury
happens with the stool and it seems to
come out of nowhere cuz I didn't know
what any of them were talking about I
said spoiler someone gets hurt with a
stool he should follow than her head
hits this one like [ __ ] thanks for
the premise of Million Dollar Baby
that's the premise I read that probably
was like this much of importance but for
me that was the climax of the film oh so
did she come back from a tour was the
rest of the film her being injured for
life no that's it that's it I mean I
think I was like 12 uh-huh why are your
feet on me cuz it's comfortable but for
you yeah okay
don't what else you excited for this
week I'm excited to get a little bit of
sleep because we didn't get sleep before
we left and then we didn't get sleep
because we were at a wedding and we
stayed up late and mm-hmm to Queens so
he squeezed in that's all they had I was
just cute she was like it's two doubles
okay I'm like yeah of course cuz we've
done there's a dollar that's it so we
have like one bed to put all our stuff
on and then we squiggle in oh yeah real
real cozy in that one it was super small
yeah like I've Sears me the Kings it was
fun but I do we didn't get great how is
it that you're more tolerable to sleep
next to in a smaller bed then you are a
bigger bed because in our bed which is a
king-size bed it's a plenty big bed for
two people our size it's not like either
of us are particularly tall or long or
lanky you know what I mean Julian just
like I will push you off of me a harder
times the night because it's like the
bigger the bed the more you just start
to just sprawl out and I'm like sitting
on the edge of the bed with all three
dogs like this like can you just like
move over an inch but in a double bed it
didn't bother me at all they say you
give him in the world spread out and you
give him a tiny cell and he stays
compartmental his boy who said that mark
nobody said that mark is a character
that JSON has created where he just
spouts nonsense
sorry he like spouts nonsense about
nothing hmm and it's like just English
very weird English words like to be
quite a literary later date and
announced and from - furthermore and
then oh man I miss those guys god it's
been too long since I played Oh Julian
there's a pub Jia fiction Oh anyway
we're probably gonna like eat our food
now and like asleep pretty soon but
hopefully you'll excuse the wacky little
podcast you know what's getting better
though in terms of videogame addictions
for real cuz I know that's a real thing
so I'm trying to like make light if
anyone really does have that but my
needing to play all their Scrolls 24/7
stopped once I hit max level because I
realized that there's nothing left for
me to do well yeah I can only do 12 min
trials and it's also you don't do a lot
of pvp right no not that much yeah CPU
not good enough well pvp you play until
you've either given up because you feel
like everyone else has been on you which
is how I kind of end up in Call of Duty
well it's different knowledge scrolls
like you I know you can one-on-one fight
people but like in order to do the real
PvP areas you need to have like friends
the way that you play pop GE the Quadro
thing as I was I don't know anybody so
although I do have a group of friends
you have plenty of friends on there I
believe a friends I like playing with I
don't know I'm gonna eat and see if I'm
gonna throw up tonight or like if I'm
alive forward rough shape guys yeah
really don't feel good sometimes you
just gotta be in your own unfiltered
rough shape sometimes you just gotta do
the side work it is one third of this
country knows what side work is are you
saying the two thirds of the country who
never heard of a part-time job
gibberish bit like it's my [ __ ] me
didn't you say something the other day
that was like a comment those mind
[ __ ] you I feel like people do it on
purpose
ever since I said the is vegan takes
medicine okay yeah give me mine [ __ ]
comments on purpose oh yeah Twitter joke
about the Mayweather McGregor fight and
it had a picture of McGregor in his
corner and his 3/4 man who had like like
basically like sharing some waiters they
had these vests on yeah and some of the
captain was like the hardest thing
McGregor had to do is figure out which
like hipster briefs that he was in my
coffee from and I liked it because my
stupid funny joke and someone tweeted at
me you're better than this
or something along lines of lucky you're
better than lighting this week cause
like what my [ __ ] boy that's my boy
that's a mind [ __ ] you're better than
this what like you know funny joke look
and really did look like they were in
serve him my craft beer it's a funny
joke that's why I liked it I dunno just
like maybe they were just a die-hard
McGregor fan they really don't laugh in
a DS fight that's all I wanted I just
I'm excited as this fight that's it pop
for sehri to be putting more effort
towards their fights again their
promotions again and have it be felt
back up because we're all in need of
some good MMA but guys thanks again for
hanging out with us feel free to leave
podcast ideas in the description we saw
in the comments sorry for being a sauce
oh I'll guarantee you guys that a lot of
times when we're looking for ideas we
look right in these comments so leave
your ideas and we might we might do it
and this Friday will be on the h3
podcast we'll give you guys more details
about that later
[Music]
but thank you guys we'll see you next
week two-thirds of this country doesn't
even know what side work is I feel like
I'm gonna vomit
just like peachy guys our dog threw up
in our podcasts question mark
[Music]